and then there's the among a number of
other things the issue of surveillance
which is directly related to journalism
not just because journalists will have
trouble getting sources and keeping
sources out of jail or themselves under
a pervasive surveillance regime but
surveillance is really a deadening thing
to societies in all kinds of ways not
just journalists this is a this deadens
it chills speech it will chill almost
everything and we should all be thinking
about how we can I think how we can not
have pervasive surveillance though our
governments plural and corporations
plural are doing their damnedest to make
sure we don't get a choice maybe we
should be working harder ourselves to do
things this by the way that is part of
the book I'm working on has to do with
what we can do to regain some control
what I don't want to see is a world
where we need permission and that's what
centralized control requires is
permission from other people I don't
want permission in particular in the
context of tonight to publish or to
speak that's that's wrong that's bad we
have to prevent that and I just want to
say again that this incredible
technology revolution which I still
believe is more good than bad by a long
margin is not something that should be
controlled at the center or by
governments but by us that's hard to do
though easy to say
[Music]